je suis venu ici aujourd'hui c'est pour
m'adresser à toi pas très bien à toi
là-bas toi t'as mis à belvès que je vois
ma chemise tu as mis ton parfait
déguisements d'adultes d'année à côté de
toi pareil mais quand on regarde de plus
près si je pouvais m'approcher je pense
qu'on verrait encore le petit gamin à
l'intérieur qui au mal être ou alors toi
toi quel genre de mec je pense qu'amy
l'idée à la seconde
mais qui sait pas toujours quoi en faire
ou c'est pas toi tiens tiens je te
connais tu avais beaucoup de rêves toi
beaucoup de projets mais tu t'es un peu
fait rattraper par le quotidien et la
routine et confortable et puis après
tout qui te reprochera d'avoir une vie
bien rangée
enfin pour tous les toits tout le monde
est assis là aujourd'hui je voudrais
commencer par vous poser cette question
là qu'est ce que l'enfant que tu étais
pense de l'adulte que tu es devenu vous
avez déjà pris le temps de vous poser
cette question dans mon cas l'ancien
enfant l'ancien minot marseillais et que
j'étais toujours
il aurait été le premier surpris si on
lui avait dit qu'il se retrouverait là
apparaît dans une salle devant plein de
gens parce que moi je pensais que
c'était ce cas vis des vies
extraordinaires ou alors ceux qui
sauvait des vies ou alors ce qui était
plutôt bardé de diplômes alors vie
extraordinaire je pense pas sauver des
vies mais pas que je me mette à ça c'est
risqué les diplômes
- mon rapport avec l'école c'était
plutôt un truc du genre comme ça bon
c'est une métaphore un sous les ponts
disons que j'avais plutôt un profil
autodidacte que scolaire alors j'ai
quand même eu mon bac pour faire plaisir
à mes parents mais un bac un petit peu
particulier un bac avec option chemins
de traverse
et c'est justement tout ce que j'ai
appris sur ces nombreux chemins de
traverse que je fais mieux partager avec
vous alors j'ai commencé par user les
mais pas forcément ce qu'attendaient les
parents pas ceux de la fac ceux de la
salle d'escaladé et là bas j'ai appris à
canaliser mon énergie
ensuite étant natif de marseille adore
les sports de pleine nature
je me suis tourné vers le kitesurf mais
à cette époque là ce sport là c'était
parce que c'est maintenant c'était un
sport un petit peu fait de bidouille
mais j'ai appris à explorer a essayé
tout en faisant quand même attention la
sécurité passe est un sport qui était
vraiment dangereux à l'époque
ensuite j'avais envie de faire un deux
trois moyens d'expression artistique
plus classique même si je pense que les
sports extrêmes sont carrément
artistique du coup je me tourne vers
l'écriture
alors j'ai écrit un conte philosophique
à 23 ans j'ai adoré ça mais j'ai vite
compris que ce n'était pas pour moi en
fait c'était pas assez rapide pas assez
directe scène il fallait quelque chose
de plus de plus succincts d'inform on
est en 2008
je me dis bon vu la belle vie il est
quand même temps de trouver un vrai
travail
j'avais envie de me sentir utile de
travailler au contact des gens et de
partager ce que j'avais eu la chance de
vivre jusque là du coup je me suis
tourné vers une carrière de travailleur
social plus précisément d'éducateurs
spécialisés
mais en 2008 je suis tombé aussi par
hasard un était alors que je m'ennuyais
à marseille j'ai acheté un appareil
photo et je suis tombé sur la photo et
la photo elle m'a rapidement appelé de
cette façon là et c'est quand même
compliqué de dire non quand la photo
vous appelle avec cette gueule là je
pense que vous êtes assez d'accord avec
ça c'est dur de dire non à monsieur
chabal
alors je lui ai dit je veux finir mon
diplôme d'éducateur parce que j'aime
finir ce que j'ai commencé
et puis ça me plaît pourquoi
j'arrêterais mais une fois mon diplôme
obtenu je me suis dit tu va décider j'ai
décidé en tout cas de laisser une chance
à la photo alors la chance notre ami
notre ami zinedine en sait quelque chose
la chance c'est un mot qui rend tous un
petit peu plus facile c'est un peu un
super pouvoir
parce que au début je me suis dit
at-elle photographe il a la chance de
photographier tel mec où il vient de
faire telle campagne mais qu'il ya trop
de chance dès que je me suis lancé j'ai
vite compris que derrière le mot chance
se cachait le mot travail
le mot acharnement le mot culot et
surtout le mot sacrifice comme beaucoup
de temps a passé et que ses proches
qu'on sacrifie aujourd'hui quand je
monte sur cette scène on me présente
comme artiste c'est comme ça qu'on bien
trop
c'est la case dans laquelle on mange
quand on est artiste c'est notre métier
d'avoir des idées c'est notre matière
première mais en fait on choisit pas
c'est comme ça enfin on est comme ça en
les idées viennent à nous avoir une idée
je pense que on peut l'image et pour le
résumer comme une petite étincelle c'est
un peu magique tout petit on sait pas
trop d'où ça vient mais c'est un petit
quelque chose un début mais va falloir
apprendre à transformer cette petite
étincelle en immense brasier
bon je suis désolé je suis un petit
shoot à mimer lebrazi énorme est bon
vous comprendrez d'une étincelle en
brasier dans mon métier d'artiste il est
plus simple d'exister si vous faites ce
qui se fait de tendance je pense que
vous aurez peut-être du travail on dira
même peut-être que vous êtes un grand
artiste
vous aurez du succès la belle vie la
postérité et peut-être que tout ira bien
j'ai choisi une approche peu moins
rock'n'roll un peu plus différente
je me suis dit si tu veux un jour te
prétends artistes il faut que tu crées
ta propre façon de s'exprimer autrement
dit parler de façon plus large ta propre
façon d'exister
sinon je ne considérais comme un copier
coller au mieux à peine amélioré un
simple interprète j'ai rien contre les
interprètes de ce qui se fait déjà mais
pas un artiste au sens où je l'entends
alors pour tenter de me dire artistes
j'ai créé ce que j'ai appelé le street
art 2.0 ça ressemble à ça
street art 2.0 c'est quoi je me suis dit
j'aurais peur du street art
il ya des mecs j'utilise la classique
bombes de peinture le collage ou plein
de choses futiles ils font déjà ça très
bien pourquoi tenter de refaire ce
qu'ils font déjà c'est déjà des
champions ils sont déjà hyper abouti
dans leur domaine pourquoi ne pas tenter
de créer ma propre façon de faire du
street art réfléchit un peu j'ai montré
de portraits je viens de la photo j'aime
bien travailler les éclairages en photo
je suis dit on un outil à toi c'est la
lumière c'est l'outil que tu comprends
ce que tu maîtrises tu es à l'aise avec
ça pourquoi tu proposerait pas un street
art basé sur la projection lumineuse
ce que vous voyez derrière moi c'est une
projection lumineuse in situ dans la rue
qu'on laisse pendant un temps donné
c'est éphémère et ça disparaît quand on
est à notre projecteurs d'où le terme
2.0 j'ai remplacé la peinture par une
bombe de peinture la colle par la
technologie et qui plus est j'adorais
l'idée de proposer un street art qui
était doux dans la forme
c'est donc de la lumière ça laisse pas
quand je l'état mais ça m'empêchait pas
pour autant d'être impactant dans le
fond j'ai donc créé tenter de créer ma
façon de faire du street art pour parler
de façon plus large
j'ai tenté d'inventer mon métier alors
ça ça en impose autant à dire sur une
scène genre le mec ou ai je crée mon
métier tu vois que c'est inconfortable
au quotidien c'est vraiment vraiment
inconfortable
je vous explique jeu quand j'ai mis ce
street art au point j'ai quand même
bossé un bon moment
j'ai été voir la grande famille du
street art en leur disant imaginez un
petit chien qui vient d'avoir sa
nouvelle balle là tout content genre et
j'ai créé ce street art là qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
c'est quoi et c'est une nouvelle façon
de faire ce qu'on aime tous genres
qu'est ce que tu en penses
il va me féliciter et bien là pas du
tout ils m'ont rabattu plus bas que
terre
je me suis fait critiquer ou j'ai eu
droit à des mets ton truc sport du
street art qu'est ce que c'est que tu
fais ou alors pire que tout on a
carrément ignoré du genre mais prennent
contact livre qu'est ce qu'il fait mises
à part quelques rares exceptions merci
monsieur christophe madame dominique et
se reconnaîtront
deux ans après après beaucoup de travail
ce street art 2.0 se retrouve dans deux
livres majeurs de street art et me
demandez pas forcément pourquoi ni
comment je ne sais pas dans les livres
de français de troisième
pourquoi je vous dise ah oui pour amener
ce n'était pas le meilleur ami de
l'école tout saab on trouve ça rigolo je
mets juste d'un petit coin de ma tête
pourquoi je vous raconte ça je pense que
il y en a pas mal qui sont là parce que
ils ont envie de aussi vous vous posez
des questions ce moment vous avez envie
de trouver votre façon de vous exprimer
ou d'autres façons d'exister peut-être
que vous commencez déjà à vous avez
peut-être déjà trouvé des solutions est
en train de chercher comment les rendre
viable en tout cas je pense que quand on
s'assoit là dans cet amphithéâtre on
vient chercher ça on vient chercher
quelque part un petit coup de pied aux
fesses quand nous aider à nous lancer
alors je vous le dis vous aller déranger
vous allez interroger parce qu'on va pas
vous comprendre au début vous allez être
une petite lueur là où il y en a jamais
eu et les gens adorent les cases mais
laisser leurs biens le soin de vous
ranger dans la case qui les rassure on
me demande tout le temps mettez street
artiste et photographe
rend pas c'est pas moins de me ranger
dans une case et ça tombe bien parce que
moi mon métier c'est d'en créer
et plus vous dérangerait mieux ça sera
pour vous il ya un petit ingrédient dans
mon expérience est indispensable et qui
va vous aider à traverser toutes ses
zones de turbulences que j'appelle par
zone de turbulences et des personnes
période de doute les périodes vous en
prenez plein la gueule justement vous
avez tendance à tomber et qu'il va
falloir se relever cet ingrédient un peu
magique quelque part c'est le pourquoi
alors le pourquoi il est un peu traître
parce que quand je parle de pourquoi je
parle pas de mon projet d'aller faire du
surf à hawaï
parce que je pourrai manger des graines
de fruits bio j'ai trempé dans du
houmous et je mangerai des cocktails
pourquoi parce que c'est cool et je le
mette sur instagram j'aurai plein de
followers non non non non non non je
parle pas de ce pourquoi là du tout
quand je parle de du mot pourquoi pour
moi c'est quel message qu'est ce que
vous avez à dire qu'est-ce qui vous
habite qu'est-ce qui brûle en vous qui
fait que vous pouvez faire passer votre
petite étincelle à travers n'importe
quelle épreuve et l'a transformé en
brasier
au final qui êtes vous par rapport à vos
projets j'ai fait du street art c'était
mon idée de départ on est un sel mais
pourquoi je me suis dit que j'ai
toujours eue ancré en moi ça je ne sais
pas forcément pourquoi ce besoin
d'essayer de faire réagir l'autre pour
essayer de l'inspirer de le rendre un
peu meilleures et en gros j'ai toujours
eu besoin de montrer aux autres
regarde moi j'arrive pourquoi pas toi je
pas meilleur que toi c'est juste que
j'ai essayé de me lancer et tant que
j'aurai sa ancré en moi fouet traverser
n'importe quelle épreuve
ma petite étincelle elle va peut-être
tremblay a le fort mistral qu'on a chez
nous par exemple elle va vaciller elle
va elle va bouger mais je sais que tôt
ou tard elle va continuer à grandir et
peut-être elle se transformera en un
brasier si j'ai de la chance
rappelez vous ce que je dis sur la
chance
aujourd'hui j'ai fait un petit bonhomme
de chemin
un chemin qui m'a amenée notamment
récemment à faire une première mondiale
de street art en forêt amazonienne
mais au départ j'avais aucune connexion
dans le monde de la photo ni dans le
monde de l'art est bien pire que ça
j'avais vraiment aucune confiance en moi
quand on va parler du thème
d'aujourd'hui le pouvoir des idées ça
m'a fait prendre conscience que pour moi
le véritable pouvoir des idées et l'idée
même de pouvoir le faire je vous ai pas
raconté rapidement mon histoire pour
rien regarder un petit mec pas forcément
à l'aise dans le système scolaire
classique qui se cherche qui est curieux
mais qui sait pas trop où il va mais qui
sans le savoir au final a cru en le
pouvoir de ces idées qui a cru en l'idée
de pouvoir le faire et ça ça me surprend
encore aujourd'hui au quotidien
si on m'avait dit que je passerai de mes
expérimentations bancal de street art
dans les ruelles bienveillante de
marseille à me retrouver à projeter des
messages en plein la havane bondé de
monde pro chez des messages de liberté
d'expression au nez du gouvernement
cubain
nota bene je vous le déconseille et ou
au fin fond de la forêt amazonienne oui
je vous le déconseille au fin fond de la
forêt amazonienne ou dans les livres de
français si quelqu'un m'avait dit ça ya
deux ans et demi je redis mais non qui
n'importe quoi non n'ayez pas peur
n'ayez pas peur de croire ont le pouvoir
de vos idées parce que notre premier
frein forcément c'est nous et je le vis
encore est un autre élément que j'ai
appris sur ces nombreux chemins de
traverse
c'est que les meilleures idées celles
qui nous suivent qui nous donne la main
le plus longtemps dans notre vie c'est
pas forcément celles que vous allez
chercher c'est pas en étant sur votre
ordinateur vous dire tiens un tales a
fait sa une à fait si a peut-être non
c'est les idées que votre histoire
personnelle et je vous ai aussi pour ça
raconter mon histoire place sur votre
route
ayez confiance en sa ayez confiance en
votre histoire personnelle et vous
verrez si vous réfléchissez vous poser
un peu vous verrez que les projets qui
vous suivent le plus vous pourrez
l'observer
c'est ceux qui sont arrivés un peu comme
ça par hasard et ça c'est parce que
votre histoire
les a placés sur votre route apprenez à
faire confiance à ça alors pour conclure
pour revenir à la première question que
je vous ai posée qu'est ce que l'enfant
que vous étiez penserez de l'adulte que
vous êtes devenu je sais pas j'ai pas
rencontré le moins
en mai si ce petit minot marseillais
étaient là dans ce cercle rouge
aujourd'hui je pense qu'ils vous dirai à
tous ceux là
merci beaucoup merci
merci